good morning John it's Hank my firewire
port on my camera broke so there is no
way to get the footage from inside of my
camera into the inside of my computer so
instead of made my entire video today
with my still camera hopefully Canon
will honor the warranty on my beautiful
wonderful but non functioning HD 30 if
they don't I'm gonna pull out some more
bass so I hope that you all enjoy this
song this also unfortunately means that
there will be no truth or fail this week
I'm sorry about that it's sitting on the
inside of my camcorder what am I
supposed to do with it their loss to
Philly star she said it was stolen the
shoe says Ben wanted to help because he
had so much soul but Dennis Olaf's at
the lava he's all right now
Bregman - saw it happen yeah Giada cow
and see up - memory Geils gives me gas
and I really hate mules who's this or FS
yeah really hate news does this or
half-ass but I can't stand up by itself
it says it's too tired and the human
cannonball was late for working he got
fired and if your pants are too big you
hit exposed in the end and if you crash
your fancy guards see how a Mercedes
Benz & Cie up to glittery girls gives me
gas and I really hate new rules cuz
they're so half assed ya really hate we
lose cuz they're so half-ass
I forgot how to throw a boomerang but
then it came back to me it's like riding
a bike you're playing with you know
painter Exorcist you'll get repossessed
the Pirates shot himself so he could
have that Dead Man's Chest and the co2
delivery guy always gives me gas and I
really hate news cuz there's a fast
ya really hate news cuz they're so
half-assed ya really hate me
who's this rappers yeah hate me
whose cuz they're so healthy
[Music]
now I'm going to show you some footage
from my live show in Cambridge
Massachusetts which was an absolutely
amazing show and we had Eve's TPA
Records have decided to make that show
available as a live album for a mere ten
dollars you can get it right now at
dftba.com it's it's still unproductively
shipping out tomorrow I wanted to do it
for those people who've been interred
federer gatherings and want to relive
the awesome that is the gathering and
also for the people who haven't been
able to come to nerdfighter gatherings
so that you can have a little slice of
that life because we could never go to
all the places where all nerdfighters
are because I think that there are some
on Jupiter and interplanetary travel is
a little dangerous these days so I don't
think we're gonna make it out there okay
that is all for now you can get my live
album it is called I'm so bad at this
live at dftba.com everything in this
song is an acronym for dftba every every
line it goes like this so it's it's a
rap song so if you weren't at LeakyCon
oh you've never heard it in acoustic
version
don't forget that brains attract darling
fetch that battle-ax Decepticons fear
this brilliant Autobot to fish take bats
a lot dogs frequently take back
apologies dreadful feudal treachery
bleeds atrocities darken forests take
bravery away dftb dftb dftba i don't
know what you man you say please explain
what is DFT